what up space fam golden here from anime
Opera and I'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest chapter
of one piece we got insane stuff
happening like the clone of a legendary
character a new devil fruit of the
hypest order Zorro greatness and much
more so make sure to stay tuned for that
if you're a Zoro stand like me smash
that like button and hit subscribe below
the video it only takes a second and it
will ensure you don't miss future videos
and updates including ones about the
epitome of Manliness Zorro and now
jumping into the chapter called the
weight of memory which is an amazing
title once once we finish the chapter it
makes a lot of sense first we get what
looks like some written info by vegapunk
saying even if the world does not accept
how she came to be the girl is
unmistakably human it was a success I
bear witness to this achievement and I
maintain that it is a huge step toward
World Peace so that seems random AF but
it could from the sounds of it be
referring to the Clone I already
mentioned and when the Clone was created
and at this point I asked myself what
can't vegapunk do with enough time and
money that's the real question we then
jump to Bonnie in kid mode crying about
hurting herself thus dragging the
actually good Vega punk in to try and
help but of course this is a ruse as
made obvious by her hilarious twinkling
eyes she then becomes big using
distorted future it not only makes her
older but more muscular it's cool that
there is so much more to this fruit than
we thought and you can get more creative
by distorting quote unquote the future
Vega Punk Dodges her attack but it's
very strong strong enough to break the
wall and this form definitely seems
fitting for Kuma's daughter I must say
she then uses timely thrust on him and
that turns him into a helpless trial
definitely a cool ability Bonnie has to
work with here we can assume Advanced
hockey users can counteract its effects
when used on them if they really needed
to but for most people this could really
cause trouble for them I also love how
kid vegapunk begs to have his golden
years back even though he was 65 years
old interestingly enough Bonnie points
out that her power doesn't last forever
on living things Advanced hockey Mastery
or not I'm but I gotta say having her
close at hand for Luffy and Zoro to even
briefly enter their prime years would be
Beyond valuable not to mention how
distorted Futures could potentially help
them too back to the chapter and of
course Bonnie wants to know why Mega
Punk took her father's life Vega Punk
still can't answer and then we jump to
Kuma climbing the red line people are
even like no way he makes it to the top
it's like the Mount Everest of one piece
and Kuma is panting hard but at the same
time not giving up while this is
happening we're getting the conversation
between vegapunk and Kuma's daughter
where the scientist is explaining that
he promised to keep Kuma's secret no
matter what man they are really building
up this secret so I'm hoping it will be
worth the wait and anticipation when
it's revealed and it looks like it's
going to be revealed real soon as we'll
get into Mega Punk insists that no one
made the decision for Kuma he chose his
fate for himself Bonnie is mad though
saying he would never choose to die and
abandon her but vegapunk just says it's
been hard for him too and he wishes he
could forget the whole ordeal and that's
gonna be a funny comment when we see
what's gonna happen later on as well the
ability to forget stuff but more on that
soon so although the truth hasn't been
explained yet we can assume that
vegapunk tried to talk Kuma out of it
but Kuma insisted and so vegapunk
against his will in a sense carried out
his friend's wishes and I kept saying
that Vega Punk had a good reason and
it's definitely looking that way now so
good guy vegapunk for the win I really
like how Mega pun goes on to praise His
Friends saying Kuma's an incredible man
interesting that at least his
translation uses the present tense too
he continues I've always been proud to
call him my close friend Bonnie please
understand I can't say anything more on
the matter and yeah that sounds like bro
code you made a promise you gotta keep
it even if a girl is beating you up my
respect is growing for Kuma and vegapunk
in this chapter I must say however
obviously Oda has to reveal the truth to
us somehow so he has Bonnie noticed
something and vegapunk very suspiciously
says pay no attention to what's over
there it's got nothing to do with Kuma
of course it does though and we even see
the paw print we associate with cool up
on the door Bonnie even uses oil
breakdown to break down the lock her
powers keep getting cooler in this
chapter I can't wait to see what she can
do in a real fight she sees a huge paw
bubble like the one Zorro touched in the
iconic nothing happened moment and to
pay respect to that Goosebump inducing
moment let's just collectively smash
that like button as a nakama right now
so we get a flashback next where Vega
Punk thinks about memories they talk
about how a human loses 21 grams of mass
upon death and some consider that the
weight of the Soul it's definitely
interesting stuff Vega Punk is
fascinated that Kuma can take such
intangible things like pain and give it
physical form or even transfer it to
others the potential for scientific
experiments is definitely exciting even
for me let alone for him I love the way
he explains it as total Wireless
transmission of nerve signals he even
Wonders by that logic if it can be
applied to other nervous signals and
then brings up imagination and memories
the two of them can determine whether
those things have mass as well at first
kumas says his memories are too personal
to pull out and show to vegapunk but
vegapunk begs him for Science and
promises that nobody else will ever see
them although I have a feeling Bonnie is
about to in the present and in this way
in a sense Kuma is not gone if that
bubble is in fact his memories not to
mention we don't know 100 if some of him
is still in his pacifista body either
vegapunk probably trying to trick Bonnie
says that that bubble is nothing but
pain he tells her not to touch it since
it is more than enough to kill someone
but Bonnie says no she knows her
father's abilities too well while she's
thinking this we also see the Marines
land a direct hit on Kuma's body so he
may well be falling down before he
reaches marijuana I assume Bonnie in
some way senses that these are his
memories and she may step into them like
Zoro did to discover the whole truth
maybe as early as the next chapter and
then we'll Discover it with her
meanwhile the Marines are trying to
finish kuma off and telling the
civilians to evacuate as Kuma refuses to
stay down then back to Bonnie and ding
ding ding she does in fact say his
memories are here aren't they as she
goes to touch it but of course we don't
get the big reveal yet it could well be
in the very next chapter though Kuma for
his part starts climbing from the
beginning again and I have no doubt that
his climbing to Mary joa will make a lot
of sense when we get to see his memories
then we jump to our guys in the control
room they're not happy with Rob Lucci
and the others making it up but they do
feel confident that Zoro and Brooke can
protect the ship and me too man with
Zorro there there isn't a doubt in my
mind or a worry in my mind I gotta say
however Daft Punk points out that the
battle is far more lopsided than nusob
thinks Usopp is then shocked to see that
the seraphims followed Luchi and so now
it's their seven against R2 or at least
that is the way it looks to usop but
Daft Punk points out that it's unlikely
that cp0 ordered them in fact he says
that the seraphims are able to assess
combat situations and are equipped with
some limited decision making capability
of their own very interesting detail
there no matter how limited even a bit
of decision making could make a big
difference as at some point and it makes
these guys more interesting than if they
were just remote controlled robots that
punk points out that the enemy made a
big miscalculation because now they can
turn the seraphims back to their side
since they aka the vegapunks are higher
in the command hierarchy very
interesting stuff but somehow I don't
think it'll be quite that simple some
satellites go rushing to use their
Authority on the seraphims and they hope
Brook and Zoro can survive until they
get there although it might be
short-lived I'm excited to see Zoro
clash with strong opponents and
potentially what Seraph and mihawk too
I've been waiting for that so badly we
also get a hilarious moment when Sanji
matter of factly says who thought Moss
head would croak when the one piece is
in their sight but an angry Nami tells
him to go too since the threat affects
the whole crew love her for doing that
also I must say it made me laugh to see
Sanji say and I quote nami's orders are
absolute for mirafim and quote it's
beautiful stuff comedy gold well done
Oda I think that joke alone
deserves a smash of the like button back
to Zorro and Brooke who have to survive
we see that Kaku has awakened his
giraffe powers and he has those similar
black Flames to luchi's awakened form
unfortunately it's so hard to take a
giraffe opponent seriously especially
when he's up against Zoro Zoro snaps
saying he's had enough of fighting
Critters with the zigzagging attacks
back in wano he says he's tired of it
and sends Kaku flying with a powerful
attack I love how he just seems annoyed
rather than challenged while fighting an
awakened Zone Luchi understands the
situation and asks the seraphims to
destroy the lab before bagapan gets
there Daft Punk simply says this is bad
while Nami and usop lose it in their
Panic they'll survive no doubt but it's
still a crazy situation to be in an
attacked structure Kaku praises the
seraphims before Stasi is shown sucking
his blood so we have a Twist but also a
classic Shonen situation where a
powerful character is introduced and
then sacrificed to Hype up another one
obviously kaku's Awakening was cool but
since he was sacrificed for Stussy here
it suggests that she'll be way stronger
and that is also important because as I
mentioned no one really worried about
giraffe Kaku awakened or not even Luchi
is like what is going on we see stussy's
vampire like wings as she wipes the
blood she comments that she was just
putting him to sleep she even asks Luchi
to join Kaku saying it's time for his
cat nap you gotta love the jokes in this
chapter but in all seriousness this is
crazy and I don't know where this is
going it's pointed out that she's a
clone of Miss Buckingham Stussy of the
Rocks Pirates AKA mad's first successful
clone this is not only crazy because of
the Rock's connection and the potential
of a very hype mythical zone model
vampire fruit but also because of the
implications of cloning who else might
be a clone then Luffy whose father
Dragon was so close to vegapunk or maybe
Zorro who looks so much like Ruma the
sword God Luffy could even be a clone of
Roger Joy boy we know there's a crazy
amount of similarities there and what
about Blackbeard in this connection to
zebic could it be a clone connection
Nothing is for sure obviously at this
point but the possibilities are crazy to
think about what an amazing hype chapter
that was and I love how this girl who I
was hoping can keep up with Lucci seems
even more powerful now is she gonna
actually help the straw hats for some
mysterious reason or is she going to
turn on them after she takes down Luchi
as she said so exciting and keep in mind
Kizer is on his way and Blackbeard is
fighting law and GARP is going after
Blackbeard and kid is at elbaf and
Shanks and you get the point things feel
crazy and out of control right now in
the best way another group perhaps my
favorite to keep your eyes on right now
are of course the former Warlords and
our new updated video on them link on
screen and in the description below is a
great way to see what they're bringing
to this crazy table that is one piece
right now